worlds collided in 2023's The Flash and
the DC Multiverse will never be the same
again if all the alternate universes and
time travel Shenanigans seem impossible
to keep track of this is your Guide to
the ending of Barry Allen's big
adventure Major Spoilers ahead
The Flash is an elaborate Dimension
hopping Adventure that all starts with
one choice Barry Allen's decision to run
back in time and stop his mother's
murder the trouble is that Barry's
Choice sets off a chain reaction that
brings him back to an entirely different
present one in which a younger version
of himself has not yet become the Flash
Superman never made it to Earth and
General Zod is about to attack the
planet to save the world Barry has no
choice but to team up with his younger
self an aging alternate reality Batman
and a Kryptonian Warrior named Cara at
the same time he's constantly facing a
difficult truth he has to go back and
let his mother die or the world will
never be the same again this all
culminates in a showdown that pits Barry
and his friends against Zod bury against
his own alternate self and bury against
his own emotions the choices he makes
have consequences that impact not just
his reality but everyone else's
when we meet the prime version of Barry
Allen in the flash he's been a superhero
for a while and it's clear that he has
some standing in the wider superhero
Community he's a member of the Justice
League an ally of Batman and a guy who's
got more than a few fans out on the
street
hi I love you thank you passing you into
Mr Wade no please don't despite the fame
though he's still fixated on one key
part of his life for years Barry has
worked tirelessly to find any bit of
evidence that could get his father out
of prison it's been years since Henry
Allen was wrongfully arrested for the
murder of his wife and Barry's life is a
crime lab scientist is almost entirely
motivated by his quest to exonerate his
dad the problem is that it's just not
working no piece of evidence ever seems
to be enough including surveillance
video that would have put him at another
location when Barry's mother was
murdered when that video doesn't prove
to have enough evidence Barry makes a
raging Sprint and accidentally discovers
a way to roll back time and change the
past from there his plan comes together
very quickly which helps explain why it
has so many unintended consequences and
why it's so hard for him to make the
choice that he does by the end of the
film azad's battle rages around him
Barry comes to a very difficult
conclusion he can't save everyone it's a
lesson he learns when in the midst of
turning back time to try and and save
both Supergirl and Batman from Death in
battle he realizes that they die in
pretty much every scenario that version
of Earth is doomed and it's all because
Barry went back in time to begin with
it's a lesson underlined by what happens
to his alternate Barry who goes back to
try and fix things so many times that he
turns monstrous Full Of Heartache Barry
makes the hardest possible Choice he
goes back in time again and changes
reality back to the one in which his
mother is murdered and his father is
imprisoned it's an important decision in
his larger Journey as a hero and it
proves his maturity when it comes to
understanding the greater good it's also
an important emotional climax in which
Barry finally realizes what both
versions of Batman tried to teach him
our tragedies make us who we are whether
we like it or not
Barry's alternate itself joins the
action in The Flash several years
earlier than his prime Universe
counterpart and it shows he's not just
more immature than the berry we've come
to know but he hasn't even gotten his
superpowers yet and when he finally does
get them he doesn't exactly prove
himself the most capable it's for these
reasons that Barry doesn't tell his
younger self the reason why he came back
in time to begin with that is until the
alternate reality Barry overhears him
this information changes everything for
the younger Berry while the primary
spends the film coming to the
realization that he has to let go of the
past in order to save the future the
alternate Barry thinks that he can stop
tragic events from happening by reliving
them over and over again as a result he
runs himself right into becoming a super
villain altering reality so many times
that he risks destroying an entire
Multiverse of Worlds if they Collide but
as he meets his end at his own future
self's hands his last Act is to
sacrifice himself to save his prime
counterpart despite everything he
manages to go out as a hero when we meet
the alternate universe's version of
Batman his crime fighting career is
already over he's living alone in a
Dusty run-down version of Wayne Manor
with nothing to do all day but drink and
grow out his beard as he explains to the
berries it turned out this way because
he did his job a little too well Gotham
City no longer has a crime problem and
they no longer need Batman as a result
this version of Bruce Wayne is a lost
man someone with no real sense of
purpose now that his singular mission is
seemingly complete meeting the two
berries and eventually Supergirl helps
Batman see A New Path forward for
himself he's so reinvigorated that he
eagerly shaves straps the suit back on
and goes into battle alongside his new
friends it's a fight he clearly relishes
partially because he's never fought
alongside metahumans before but mostly
because he has a purpose again you want
to get nuts
let's get nuts as the climactic battle
rages and the Barry's time traveling
proves useless in changing the outcome
it's clear that Batman is meant to die
trying to save Earth from General Zod
it's tragic but not for Bruce Wayne
himself for him it's a good way to go
out doing something to help others
fighting evil for as long as he can as
hard as he can
by the time we meet Supergirl in the
flash she's been locked up and drained
of her energy for years she's furious at
Humanity so when Barry comes knocking
she's not sure why she should fight for
them Cara's mind changes thanks to the
kindness and Persistence of her new
friends and Rescuers and she starts to
grasp what the stakes of the conflict
truly are when she realizes zod's
intentions in this universe she's the
Kryptonian Refugee who contains the
genetic key to the future of her species
her cousin Kalel was apparently a spare
who died when he was a baby when Zod
hints that he might have been the one
who killed the child Cara flies into a
rage ready to battle to her last breath
unfortunately for her though this is the
universe where Zod wins no matter how
hard she fights she'll end up dead at
zod's hands sadly for Cara that's the
end of her character Arc but her
presence in the film and the hard
lessons taught by her story Drive Barry
to go back in time and restore his own
past now that we've established a
Multiverse within DC though it feels
like Kara could re-emerge likely with a
more hopeful narrative
throughout the flash the prime Barry
Allen is subjected to occasional visits
from a dark character in Black who seems
to have all of his speed but none of his
morals the villain's overall look and
his status as a fellow Speedster
suggests the arrival of savitar a DC
Comics villain who appeared as an
alternate Barry Allen in The Flash TV
series at the end of the film this
savitar style monster does indeed appear
as another version of alternate Berry
specifically another version of Barry's
alternate Ally who spent years running
through the Multiverse trying to reverse
time and defeat Zod in the process he's
had Kryptonian metal embedded in his
body time and time again turning him
into a scarred fiend who's in constant
pain but is still convinced that he can
fix everything if he just keeps running
this version of Barry is ultimately
killed when his own past itself the
alternate Barry sacrifices his life to
save primary his presence acts as a
cautionary tale for primary who realizes
at long last that he has no other choice
but to embrace his own past pain and awe
savitar doesn't exist for very long in
the Flash Film but his actions and his
monstrous appearance teach a very
important lesson
at the end of The Flash Barry Allen
realizes the only way to save the
present is to go back in time and
restore his original reality but that
doesn't mean that he doesn't change
anything while his mother is doomed to
die Barry still finds a way to save his
father by altering the grocery store
surveillance cameras to show him in
Clear View that's the final piece of
exonerating evidence that gets Henry
Allen out of prison you can be whatever
you want to be you're brilliant man
absolute best of the best father and son
are finally reunited after far too long
apart what's key of course is that
Barry's father doesn't actually know
that his son is The Flash or that he
managed to engineer his release Beyond
his work at the crime lab it'll be
interesting to see if future films ever
give us a glimpse of how the pair's
relationship evolves
the last time we see Primary in the main
Narrative of The Flash he's just managed
to free his father but there are still a
few dangling threads at the end of the
film for one thing there's Iris West
Barry's old friend who seems to have
taken a liking to him in the comics they
end up as a couple and iris's nephew
Wally West becomes a new Flash further
down the line is there romance budding
only time will tell if another Flash
Film comes to pass that is then of
course there's the matter of Bruce Wayne
as Barry leaves the Central City
Courthouse he's greeted by Bruce's car
but it's not either of the bruises he's
met in his place is yet another Batman
suggesting that something in the
Multiverse has been broken by Barry's
rescuing of his father
over the course of its run time the
flash deploys two very big cameos that
are worth breaking down at the very end
of the film Barry learns that his
universe's new Bruce Wayne looks just
like George Clooney who previously
played the Caped Crusader in 1997's
Batman and Robin though it's gotten
something of a reappraisal in recent
years that film has long been a subject
of mockery for its campy tone by
introducing him at the last minute The
Flash gives Clooney a small measure of
redemption while also throwing the
audience a big laugh I want a car
chicks dig the car
this is why Superman works alone then
there's another crazy cameo in the
Multiverse sequence during which we also
see Superman resembling George Reeves
and Christopher Reeve there's another
Superman that appears though he's
fighting a giant alien spider creature
while sporting long hair and a
determined expression on a closer look
it's revealed that this Superman looks
exactly like Nicolas Cage it's all an
elaborate nod to Superman lives an
abandoned Superman Project from the
1990s in which cage would have played
the character for director Tim Burton
the spider creature in particular is an
abandoned concept from that film but
somewhere out in the Multiverse cage got
to be the man of steel after all
near the end of The Flash we see the
mass of DC Multiverse as worlds start to
collide over the course of this sequence
we Glimpse several different Earths all
with their own metahumans fighting
various battles just as Batman warned
earlier in the film Barry's insistence
on creating more and more inflection
points has led to a tangle of alternate
worlds all of them now in danger what we
do know based on the film's ending is
that primary's decision to go back and
fix his original timeline brought some
stability to the universe again what we
don't know just yet is what those
actions mean for The Wider Multiverse do
those worlds still exist and if so are
they at all aware of each other is the
upcoming DC Universe also a part of that
Multiverse these are lingering questions
that aren't quite answered not even in
the post-credits sequence
after the main narrative is over the
flash shows us a brief post-credits
scene in which Barry and Aquaman come
stumbling out of a bar Barry's been
chatting with Arthur about what he just
experienced particularly how there are
different Batman in different universes
meanwhile Arthur is a little too drunk
to keep track of it all it's a fun
little scene but it doesn't answer any
of the questions that viewers have been
left with since the ending proper what
the hell is this does the Bruce Wayne of
primary's world look like George Clooney
now or did Barry go back and find a way
to restore the Ben Affleck version to
the timeline it's not exactly clear but
Barry does refer to all the alternate
Batman in the past tense so maybe it's
all changed after all we'll just have to
wait for more DC Adventures to know for
sure
in the months leading up to the release
of The Flash fans became aware of some
major changes over at DC Studios as
co-ceos James Gunn and Peter Safran have
taken over as masterminds of the future
of the DC Universe on the big screen gun
has been pretty clear that he intends to
produce many new stories from scratch
and that includes the casting of a new
Superman what we still don't know is how
this will affect characters like The
Flash Wonder Woman Aquaman and other
established DC Heavy Hitters it's pretty
clear from the way the flash ends that
if they so choose gun and saffron could
continue telling stories with these
characters in several ways they could
simply say that the Earth that Barry
went back to when he released his father
from jail the present is now a different
world with alternate versions of certain
Heroes like George Clooney as Batman or
they could start from scratch and pick
and choose which actors to bring back
however it works out the flash
definitely leaves some major
possibilities open